it takes a little while for most
americans to whip a french name but in
the case of motion picture stars who
come here from france there is plenty of
time because they remain stars for many
years
having finally nailed down the
pronunciation of charles boyle
the
the american theater goer may now start
to work leisurely on louis jordan
he'll be on hand for quite a while
mr jordan will present the special award
for the best foreign language film
ladies and gentlemen mr you're done
thank you bob
it is a real honor for me a newcomer to
america
to present the award for the best film
produced in a foreign language
voted by the board of governors of the
academy as the best foreign language
film for 1948
is the french film monsieur song
the award will be accepted by mr
alexander de marzieli french consul
general in los angeles
it gives me great joy and pride
to accept this award
on behalf of all those
who are responsible
for the film mr vasso
their combined
efforts and talents especially those of
the producer leon carrey
the director
maurice plush
and the unforgettable
performance of pfrna
have made it possible for this film to
achieve
such universal
appeal and significance thank you
thank you very much mr jordan